as for the pitching tonight chris
paddock looking for another good one i
think he was very strong the other night
in philadelphia and dealing with much
better conditions in terms of weather
soto at 277
with nine doubles 10 homers and 39 runs
batted
in that one is hit well to left
c
u
later
number 400 for soto on hits
bang zungo soto the opposite way with a
line drive
three-run home run
announced today that he'll participate
in the home run derby in denver
coming up next monday night
271 five homers 27 runs batted in for
harrison
chris is set here's the pitch and he
just kind of serves it out into center
field grisham tracking it over towards
left center a little bit squares it up
makes the catch and the inning comes to
a close it was a long one patrick corbin
on the hill for the nationals we
obviously saw him a bunch in his
diamondback days it's been an ugly
couple of years for patrick corbin so
now they're loaded up for eric hosmer
grisham at third
machado at second
meyers at first
one ball two strikes the count of the
pitch swinging a ground ball right side
fielded by the second baseman and the
whirl and throw by escobar to bell in
time for the out of the side is retired
victor robles to lead off chris threw 31
pitches in the first inning and this 2-2
pitch tied him up swung on and missed
strike three
so a quick first out here in the second
and the first k of the night for paddock
one down with the pitcher corbin coming
up and he is not an automatic out at all
swinging to miss and paddock with
back-to-back strikeouts here in the
second
so josh bell stands in with the bases
loaded
crowd we're trying to rally paddock
three balls two strikes two out
the base is loaded the kick and here
comes swing and a line drive base hit
into left field
this will score two runs escobar crossed
the plate turner running on the pitch
scores easily soto to third as the throw
gets by
over toward the nationals dugout
and in the second goes bell
and the nationals lead by the score five
to nothing bell comes through
so runners on second and third now and
starlin castro the batter here's the set
3-2 to castro swung on ground ball up
the middle into center field a base hit
scoring from third is soto bell around
third coming home the throw is late and
off the mark and into second goes castro
with a single up the middle to drive in
two extends his hitting streak to ten
games in a row
and extends the nationals lead here in
san diego two out top of the second
inning four runs home it's washington
seven san diego nothing
and now yon gomes will be the eighth man
to bat in this second inning
paddock believe it or not is only in his
third season
and certainly
really struggling to find himself right
now gomes hits this one in the air to
pretty deep right field myers backing up
just on to the morning track he'll reach
up make the catch and end the inning but
the nationals get four more runs they do
so on four hits and an error they leave
a man at second base and we'll go to the
bottom of the second inning at petco
washington seven and the padres nothing
back in the first patrick got fam the
rollover ground ball to trey turner
now the pitch breaking ball fam pulled
on a slider in the dirt with a half
swing he's out the tag by gomes
completes the strikeout the first
of the night for patrick corbin here's
victor robles
the 1-0 pitch and a swing in a line
drive fair inside the third base bag
down the line this one's rolling along
the side wall toward the corner
harrison's racing around 30 is going to
try to score fams throw in will be cut
off by kim the second baseman and
harrison will score on the rbi double
for victor robles
nationals lead eight to nothing
robles has his third double of the
series his 11th rbi of the season
escobar hit by a pitch and a single
he scored two runs two one pitch
swinging a ground ball up the middle
ranging kim backhands on the other side
of second flips the tatis for a force
out at second that's all they'll get
escobar will pick up an rbi with robles
scoring corbin erased on the force out
that's the first out of the fourth and
the nationals lead nine to nothing
fernando over one he flew out to deep
right field back in the first inning
one two swing and a miss corbin puts
away tatis with a nasty slider
down and out of the strike zone so
corbin has his second consecutive
strikeout josh harrison is one for two
chris matt to the plate
curveball ground ball right side through
for a base hit rounding third castro
coming home he will score without a
throw josh harrison picks up his 28th
rbi of the season the nationals have
scored now in each inning and they've
hit double digits the nationals 10 and
the padres nothing
now corbin at the dish
first and second two down first pitch
and corbin slaps it the other way but
manny is there machado's got it looked
at second and decides to go to first
base instead that'll end the inning and
the nationals get only one run here in
the top of the fourth inning do it on a
couple of hits and they also leave two
men
on board we have played three and a half
innings at petco park washington is in
complete command of this game 10 to
nothing nationals
[Laughter]
josh harrison
is two for three tonight with a run and
an rbi
he's feeling good out there
winning the hearts of fans on the road
the bill chris matt is going to get a
chance to bat here because
chase tingler needs innings after a
starter
recorded only six outs
the o2 struck him out swinging corbin
retires chris matt and we go to the
fifth that will bring in tatis and
corbin delivers swinging by tatis in a
line drive caught by a sprawling turner
to his right to his knees
good play by turner runner on third two
outs for manny machado
3-1 manny with a rocket over trey turner
into left center field for a base hit
tommy pham will come in to score machado
with another hit and the padres on the
board here in the bottom of the fifth
inning
here's john gomes gone one for three
to one pitch is it on the ground to
matteo again jorge kind of falls down
gets himself up throws to first in time
nicely done by mateo eric hosmer will
lead off against washington starter
patrick corbin
back on the hill patrick corbin here's
the drive out to deep right center field
for hosmer
and that is gone a home run
home run number seven of the year for
hosmer
padres get their second run to come the
friars
here's hassan kim here's the wine in the
delivery swinging a hard ground ball
backhanded deep and short by turner gets
to his feet fires across on one hop and
it's in time for the out
fine play by trey turner sprawling to
his backhand
escobar on three times hit by a pitch
single reach on a fielder's choice
and then chris matt took over in the
third inning there he is in the seventh
with one on the fly ball to center has
grisham coming in full bore
and the dive to make the catch
two down here in the seventh for trey
turner
pitch is a hard hit grounder off the
right side of the mound diving stop pro
far bounce throw to first in time let's
hang another one why not
runners first and third
one out and john gomes would be the
batter
and the pitch swung on line drive left
center toward the gap that'll get down
grisham cuts it off before the warning
track soto scores from third heading two
third his ballot into second is gomes
after some hesitation around first
runners second and third for josh
harrison
and the pitch swung on line drive down
the left field line base it that will go
into the corner bell scores from third
gomes around third he will trot home and
into second with his third hit of the
game a double and two runs bannon as
josh harrison is now driven in three
runs of the game tonight now gerardo
parra will bat for the second time
vermeer is ready and they owe 0-1
swinging the ground ball left side off
the glove of mateo sprawling to get it
and out into left-center field so
harrison who is off and running from
second of the pitch around third comes
in to score
and para is aboard with a hit in an rbi
and four runs are home here in the top
of the eighth inning next up castro gets
another a b
ramirez sets
two old delivery swinging a tapper
toward the middle charging and hassam
kim has it
and throws to first for the out coming
in from third to score is yadiel
hernandez and it's now the nationals 15
and the padres two trent grisham coming
up with fam on first base
the drive to deep right field off the
bat at grisham and that ball is gone
trent grisham with his 11th home run of
the year it's a two-run shot
it's 15-4 padres getting a couple runs
here
trying to finish on a good note victor
caratini will come to bat for the first
time tonight he came on to play first
base in the top of the inning
liner into left field for a base hit
from third
comes mateo with the fifth padres run
is making some noise here in the bottom
of the ninth inning not going quietly
webster reevos the catcher one out of
four
they're kicking the pitch swinging a
miss struck him out with the elevated
fastball and a curly w w's in the books
in san diego